alright guys welcome to this video we're
going to be breaking down the
interconnected relationship between
flexibility and technique when it comes
to kicking quite a common thing that
tends to happen is when people will see
a certain technique performed they'll
see how dynamic and sort of explosive it
looks perhaps and they will think wow
that must take a huge degree of
flexibility to be able to perform so
really common thing that I tend to
notice on this is on YouTube comments if
I'm looking through videos of like kick
in or maybe people were messaged me on
social media and saying something like
you know I want to be able to perform X
Y Z kick any tips on developing the
flexibility to be able to do this with
no mention of really anything else so I
think this video should be really useful
if you've already got some experiencing
kick in and you wanted to improve in
something but perhaps you don't know
what's kind of holding your technique
back or getting in your way of getting
to that next level
now I mentioned in a previous video that
having a decent level of flexibility is
obviously an imperative thing to be able
to kick effectively and not get injured
and things like that usually though in
people when they want to improve it's
not actually the flexibility that's kind
of their problem and the things that
they need to work on are kind of a
little bit more hidden under the surface
so we'll call that this person's
paradigm so a simple way to describe a
paradigm is basically a set of
assumptions that we have that influence
the way we make our decisions so in this
case the person who is wanting to
improve their kicks paradigm would be
that I need to improve my flexibility in
order to be able to do this kick but
like most things in life often the
source of what's causing those problems
is kind of underneath the surface which
is a little bit tricky to identify
because it's not kind of right in front
of you and you don't always know where
to look for it and that's the same with
this situation so how this relates to
training then is if a person believes
they've identified the source of why
they're not able to perform in the way
they want to say in terms of our example
its flexibility they'll be looking at
that area and focusing solely upon that
and unfortunately they may never
actually look under the surface and
discover the real reason of what's kind
of causing them problems or more
accurately doing things that are not
going to kind of yield them the most
benefit for the the effort that they're
put in him and the 80/20 principle seems
to be some kind of universal law in
which 20% of effort tends to yield 80%
of resorts and this occurs in so many
different areas like for instance how if
you want to improve your body
composition it's 80% diet and 20%
exercise and flexibility is exactly the
same in that regard so you could stretch
for years and years and years and
develop an incredible level of
flexibility but then still have poor
kicks with like a hunched posture and
not really have any understanding of why
well then you come across somebody who
point something out to you and you make
a slight tweak to your technique and
then all of a sudden it's like kind of
the lights go on in a darkened room and
you're suddenly able to do the technique
way way better than you were four years
before in order to illustrate this point
in a second we're gonna look at a clip
that one of the viewers sent me of a
spin hook kick and he was looking for
some tips on how to improve it to make
it much more kind of sidon and
controlled as he was coming around so as
you can see his kick isn't bad by any
means he's got very good control over
his body and good rotational force going
around but in order to really get that
sidon turned hit position what is doing
here is is going too far around with his
pivoted foot this is the starting point
for which everything else is kind of
happening from here because his foots
facing this direction
his toes are facing about here and it's
heel off towards here it's knocking the
alignment of his whole body off into the
kick and he's not able to open his hips
correctly so in this position it's
almost impossible to really turn those
hips in the right position and often
people will try and do that and kind of
injure themselves by twisting one join
one way and one join the other way so
the beginning part is all in this
pivoted foot so really if you wanted to
open those hips correctly you would need
to have this heel facing towards the
camera and his toes facing backwards
more so that would look more like this
one you see as the kicking position
happens here my heel is facing a
complete towards the camera and it's
allowing me to be in that nice
completely opened up position as opposed
to being kind of folded up in this tight
position if that makes sense
and once you do that that gives you much
more control over the kick coming
through so then these clips are when
he'd applied what I've mentioned to do
with the foot positioning and literally
all it done really was change the
position of his foot and AD and not
going to affect the rest of the whole
move and allowed him to much more easily
open up his hips into this into this
nice open position and be much more
controlled throughout the whole kick and
this pivoting of the foot in the
positioning is really one of the most
important things that's going to
determine how a kick goes afterwards
because it's one of the first things to
happen and it's often the thing when you
see somebody who's really struggling to
kind of perform kicks with any kind of
power and explosiveness and there's a
few basic areas that are really going to
go a long way too
improving your kicks and for the sake of
ease we're just going to break these
down into two distinct categories one is
things that are part of a technique and
a mental conception of what goes into a
move and the second is the physical
exercises or drills that you can do to
make that technique better and that is
the category that flexibility falls into
but almost everything in that category
comes secondary on the list so this is a
point that I keep hammering home all the
time because it's really going to
improve your skills exponentially if
you're able to grasp it and focus on it
the thing that needs to come first is a
conceptual understanding of how a
specific technique works the certain
body positions in alignment and things
like that and the reason this comes
first is it can be practiced mostly
without addition of the second category
so improving things like flexibility and
strength and all that kind of stuff can
almost be viewed in a sense like add-ons
or what sometimes known as a force
multiplier so force multipliers are
tools that help you amplify your effort
to produce more output but it's
obviously really important to have a
degree of balance in all areas and too
much of one side it will always tip the
scales and leave you with problems in
other areas and this is basically the
point I'm trying to get across in this
video is that obviously I'm not saying
flexibility isn't important and
technique is only important it's a
degree of balance and not to just only
think of one area with neglect to the
others and the same thing goes for all
of these videos as well you know I may
present one element of training but
that's by no means intended to be all
you need to do and again people's
paradigms state to them that one thing
should take precedence over another and
this goes for many areas in life when we
identify with just one side or one pole
of a certain binary opposite and
whenever we find ourselves in rigid
ultimate thinking we're going to have a
problem now when you've got a decent
level of flexibility you're obviously
going to continue to stretch to improve
yourself as you keep going throughout
your journey of training but once you've
attained that level which is relatively
easy there's going to be other things
that are going to be influencing the way
you move you will more than likely have
a natural proclivity towards one side of
a pole but in order to really kind of
reach your highest potential you're
going to need to work upon the areas
that are not so natural to you in order
to improve those and bring them up to a
similar sort of level now I'm not saying
you can't have your preferences
obviously there's going to always be
certain things that you want to do and
have sort of preferences towards but be
flexible and adaptable to know where you
need to change and this is how real like
high-level athletes train
they kind of understand where their weak
areas are and they spend time on them
even though it's uncomfortable and not
really enjoyable because you might be
kind of stumbling all the time or you're
just kind of clumsy where you learning
something so most people don't really
want to do this though because it
doesn't feel great and it's like when
they start to actually push those limits
and kind of you know train things that
are not as comfortable for them the
brain doesn't reward them as much and it
starts to make them feel kind of pretty
[ __ ] about about what they're doing so
they'll just kind of fall back into old
habits and back into that comfort zone
again and not really grow and what I'd
recommend here is that before jump into
conclusions about what's going on with
your own kicks firstly is to film
yourself then examine closely the
technique of somebody doing the move who
you consider to be good at it and kind
of compare yourself against that person
so let's now have a little bit of a
technical breakdown of a side kick and
this is a kick that often people
struggle to know how to get all of the
right elements in place to make it kind
of work correctly so when looking at a
side kick or when training it is easy to
assume obviously that you need a super
high level of flexibility especially
because it's quite an iconic kick that
you often see photographs of and things
where people are doing it really high
but unless you know those kind of little
things that they're going into it's
going to almost be impossible to be able
to perform it like that or anything
close to that one of the main things
that you tend to see people do again
going back to this pivoting of the foot
issue if this isn't into the right
position when you start in the hole move
the rest of its gonna go off now what
happens with my foot here I tend to move
it in different stages as the kick
happens so we'll call this the beginning
stage which I've already kind of turned
it slightly as I begin so I'm in my
forward-facing stance here as a
beginning the kick I already turn it 45
degrees so I've done a little bit of the
work straightaway and as I lift the kick
into the chambered position say we'll
call this position number two I've then
turned it about 90 degrees side woods so
that's half of the pivot in position
complete already then as I extend the
kick the pivot happens fully and it's
fully facing the heel towards this
direction and the toes facing towards
this direction just to get back again
because there's something important to
do you hear and this is one of the
things here that people often tend to go
wrong with as well is when they do kick
out on their side kick if you see my
body in this type of position here or
even maybe here often people will side
kick from this position and their foot
will be here and they will side kick out
like that with their body still kind of
facing
four words which is you know still valid
but watch what I do with my body which
makes it much more powerful is you
almost turn away from the kick like this
and that creates this nice stab position
of your way along the hull of the body
which really really amplifies the power
of the technique there's a really good
clip of Joe Rogan talking about this and
trying to teach it to somebody on his
podcast who was struggling to understand
it and so if you want to see that clip
so it's just something like Joe Rogan
sidekick do with stretching it's just
you just haven't thrown a sidekick in a
while now extend extend extend straight
don't look over your stomach look over
your shoulder like that that's how you
look so yes I lift this knee up here and
turning it over the shoulder almost
looking like over my right shoulder so
you can you see my face is actually
behind the shoulder here and I'm looking
at the target of the kick then as I
bring this back up as well I'm nice and
unbalanced as I'm able to reset the
equilibrium of my weight coming back up
and then drop him down nice and lightly
without slamming my foot down which is
another issue that you often tend to see
people do is we'll go from this position
and then they will tend to slum this leg
down into the ground and then they'll
all of their central gravity will be
forwards so this is essentially the side
kicking technique if you've understood
this first part and are able to do it
well then all of the other things you do
like any stretching or any exercises to
increase your strength and explosiveness
we're only gonna make that better
however if you were to do those without
understanding this kick it's not gonna
really matter you don't want a crappy
explosive kick you know the me no we're
super high kick with poor technique it's
about having the technique first and
then being able to build on it after
that thanks once again guys I hope this
video is useful for you and if you have
any questions don't hesitate to send me
a message on any of my social media
links and also be sure to subscribe to
my youtube channel as I'm gonna start to
be creating a lot more content on there
as I mentioned in the last video thanks
very much guys and I'll see you next
time